the year is 1941 and the world is
gripped by the most violent and
widespread war
in history millions marched to war as
bloody battles are fought across the
globe
horrendous atrocities are carried out on
groups of people
and parts of london are bombed to rebel
on a weekly basis
considering it's only been 20 years
since the last world war
it must seem to the early residents of
the early 20th century
that the world is coming apart at the
seams and amongst the chaos
it'd be easy not to notice a secluded
manor house in the english countryside
disappearing without a trace for 11 days
before suddenly returning to our reality
but thankfully
one organization makes it its sole duty
to notice the unnoticeable
and understand the impossible the scp
foundation and within that anomalous
manor house
foundation agents and researchers were
about to find horrors beyond
even their darkest imaginations this
is the grim tale of scp-1461
better known as the house of the worm
when the manor house reappeared after
its 11-day absence
the foundation zeroed in sending agents
inside to investigate
it was a two level dwelling complete
with 12 bedrooms
four baths three studies a main foyer
slash ballroom
a library a kitchen and a pantry
basement
the foundation observed that a number of
these rooms had been fitted with rows of
bunk beds
similar to a boarding house or barracks
only later
would they understand why they found
that the upper portion of the home
exhibited no abnormal qualities
whatsoever
but as the agents investigated further
they found an
entrance to the truly anomalous portion
of the manor
the extensive sub-level system no
previous records of the building kept by
the local council indicated that there
would be anything below the manor's
basement
so either the mysterious previous
occupants who were nowhere to be found
had built this sub-level or had just
appeared here
on its own regardless of which was the
case
agents and researchers knew that
whatever had happened down here
had everything to do with the manor's
mysterious
disappearance they descended into the
depths of what seemed like a man-made
cave system
constructed primarily from a mix of
concrete iron
and brass it was a behemoth of 20th
century technology
intricate snaking systems of pipes gears
and pumping pistons
it was like someone had built an entire
factory down here
but for what the agents began to spread
out through the labyrinthian vowels of
the manor
hoping to find some answers but all they
seemed to discover was more
questions this place hadn't been built
with any form of comprehensible logic
it was full of dead ends stairways that
ascended and descended to nowhere
doors that would open to reveal just
walls behind them
were not open at all it was like a maze
built by a maniac
it didn't help that it looked like the
place was recently hit by an earthquake
with some passages caved in and mangled
machinery strewn about
it seemed that no human workers had
interfered with the impossibly complex
and bizarre machinery in quite some time
a number of the materials used to
construct said machinery as well as the
gray sandstone filling in the collapsed
passageways remain
unidentified to this day already the
sub-level was proving to be a complex
puzzle box with only an estimated 75
of its layout ultimately being mapped by
foundation researchers
however they would soon realize that
this place wasn't just confusing
it was deadly the only method of
self-maintenance detected by the
exploring agents were pipes that would
fire a thick black lubricant onto the
surrounding machinery
one of the foundation agents had the
misfortune of getting covered in it
while exploring a darkened passageway
and 80 percent of his body was melted as
a result
it appeared that the viscous black goo
was incredibly corrosive
to all organic matter a number of the
machines also emitted dangerously high
quantities of gamma and x-ray radiation
making it difficult to explore many of
the caverns without heavy hazmat
protection
and worst of all were the extremely
hostile creatures living in the caves
who would regularly attack foundation
personnel
these abominations came to be known as
scp-1461-1
vicious steampunk frankenstein monsters
once human but with large parts of their
bodies replaced
by crude mechanical implants including
metal teeth
and claws 1461-1s have displayed a taste
for human flesh
and they have dragged multiple
foundation agents down into their lair
to be converted
into monsters like them it's believed
that scp-1461 is capable of controlling
these beasts through the strategic use
of
sound from its brass speaking pipes
leading them into areas where foundation
personnel are present
to instigate conflict many of these
pitiful creatures have had their throats
replaced by phonographs
endlessly repeating the same nonsense
phrases
over and over again i am what you have
made me
i am choice and i am tyranny forgive me
i am then and i am now what gods they
will be then
i am evil and i am flesh i am the trap
i am beauty and i am chaos children are
selfish
i am the worm i have broken
god still in spite of the mazes monsters
and deadly chemicals
the agents persisted and managed to
discover several
important locations the gel production
chamber on sub-level 3 creates glass
jars from the unidentified
sandstone and fills them with a slime
that looks to contain
living eyes and teeth the factory
deliveries room is filled with a huge
number of crates and boxes
which seem to shift and change in number
between foundation patrols
the speaking tube room on sub-level 11
contains a grand pulpit that acts as the
connecting point for the complex array
of speaking tubes
running through the entire cave system
the body parts of a deceased female also
appear to be wired into the machinery
like spare parts and on sub-level 12
they found the so-called catalyst room
here they discovered a huge
complicated clockwork and steam-powered
machine that appeared to be broken and
missing some parts
most horrifying of all though is the
raised platform in the center of the
catalyst room
on top of which is a metal hospital bed
a desiccated male corpse rests upon the
bed
its chest punctured by large syringes
connected by tubes to some kind of
pumping machine
the parts connecting this pumping
machine to the overall apparatus of the
room were missing though
leaving its purpose a mystery the
foundation assumed that fluids used to
be drawn out of this corpse to somehow
power
the machine you may be starting to worry
that there doesn't seem to be any
answers here
that this house is one big mystery but
lucky for you
you're wrong an old journal was also
discovered in the catalyst room
and if what was written inside is to be
believed that we may finally have some
truth about who created the house of the
worm
why it was created and what horrible
events triggered its mysterious
disappearance
and reappearance his true name has been
redacted by the foundation
and special efforts have been made to
maintain secrecy around the house
seeing as it's an anomaly of great
interest to a cult known as the church
of the broken god
so we'll just call the one who made this
place the inventor
before any of this the inventor was one
of the many englishmen traumatized and
almost killed in the horrific trench
battles of world war one
after a near-death experience the
inventor like many geniuses and madmen
was plagued by surreal and nightmarish
visions
he saw a huge creature that he referred
to as the worm
a gigantic metal monstrosity with
dragon-like jaws full of gnashing gears
that rampage through europe
destroying and devouring everything in
its path
these apocalyptic visions also presented
him with a solution
vague blueprints for a machine that
might be the salvation of
him and others willing to take his new
gospel to heart
and escape from a world that the
inventor knew in his heart was about to
end
he hired work starved laborers from
across the country to help him make his
visions a reality
and began a massive secret construction
project
beneath his isolated country manor house
for the inventor it was all
a labor of love he wanted to protect his
wife
son and daughter from the terrible jaws
of the worm
but as the project stretched on his wife
began to suspect that he'd lost his mind
many of his workers however felt just
the opposite
they became infatuated by the inventor's
sermons on the nature of the worm
and the coming apocalypse they hoped to
escape soon enough they had become a
bonafide cult
constructing the elaborate sub-levels
underneath the house in preparation for
the fast-approaching day
of reckoning then came world war ii
the inventor saw hitler hungry for war
as one of the avatars of the worm
finally knowing that the time was right
he activated the machine
and successfully trapped the worm in the
bowels of his mechanized home
however as the blitz raged and london's
bombing began
the inventor felt as though he hadn't
stopped anything
he realized once and for all that he was
never meant to stop the apocalypse
only escape it and by throwing the final
switch and setting the machine
he and his followers had built into
overdrive
he did just that this was the moment
that the house of the worm disappeared
transporting the inventor his family and
his devoted staff to a different world
an empty gray world devoid of war but
also
lacking all the comforts of regular life
including
food things went downhill from there as
their supplies quickly began to run out
and the cult descended into cannibalism
in order to survive
things weren't going much better in the
inventor's personal life
his wife fearing what would happen to
the family
took her own life and the life of his
daughter though by this point
the inventor's mind was so fractured
that it's possible he may have killed
them himself
either way it was only the inventor and
his son left and more trouble
was brewing eudora one of the staff
trapped in the building with the
inventor and his cult
started a mutiny she claimed the worm
spoke to her from below
and that their only path to salvation
was pleasing the worm
how would they please it a sacrifice of
course
they would give it the son of the man
who had trapped it the mutineers took
the inventor's only remaining child and
descended into the lowest sub-levels
the inventor followed hoping to track
them down save his son
and salvage something from this
nightmare as he ventured deeper
battling the members of eudora's new
cult he found that they were changing
themselves
becoming the half-human cyborg creatures
that the foundation would later discover
the inventor would find eudora herself
in the speaking tube room
her body still living was wired into the
machinery
and she had sacrificed his son to the
worm in a rage the inventor murdered
eudora
or whatever was left of her then heard a
familiar voice speaking out of a nearby
speaking tube
it said i am what you have made me i
am then and i am now i am choice
and i am tyranny i am evil and i am
flesh i am beauty and i am chaos
i am the worm the voice
was his own in that terrible moment the
inventor realized that the worm wasn't a
giant all-devouring monster
it was him in trying to protect his
loved one from a perceived apocalypse
he brought them all to their horrible
demise he'd trapped them with the
monster he'd hoped for them all to
escape from
because no matter what you build you
can't escape from who you are
grief stricken and broken the inventor
descended into the catalyst room
there was his son stuck with the
syringes
drained of all life to fuel the mighty
machine
his father had created in his last
moments
the inventor decided to do the only
noble thing
he threw himself into the machine
destroying both it
and himself in the process the house was
transported back to our own reality
but the worm in a sense was no more
but who knows if the worm is really dead
its thoughts and poisonous intent still
lingers in the caverns
and rattles through the speaking pipes
whatever really happened
the foundation is still picking up the
pieces today and who knows what lurks in
the parts still hidden from
our knowledge now go check out scp-082
ferdinand the cannibal and scp-2935-o
death for more fascinating freaky files
from the foundation